Transcriber: Ghadir Atwi
المدقّق: Rana Al kilaney
Hello
Hope you’re doing well
My name is Nidal Ghaith
Today I want to tell you a story
I hope it inspires you
and grant people patience and endurance
and I hope you like my performance
God bless you
This happened 10 years ago or more
I was at home one night
My phone rang at 5:00 am
It was a call from Germany
My wife was studying in Germany
She and my son were there
The number was anonymous
I answered
It was the phone call that changed my life
as well as other people’s lives
My little family that I longed for
My world, my ambition, and everything
I aspired for to live a happy life
Everything was about to collapse
because of this phone call
They told me that my 10-month-old son
was suffering in the hospital
Yes, the hospital and that I had to
be there in no time
I was an ambitious young man, just married
and it was my first baby
It was a very big shock for me
For no reason, I had told my wife before
,that if something happened to Abboud
I wouldn’t know how I would feel
I was very confused and disappointed
I didn’t know what to do
I grabbed whatever money I had at home
and took a car
I only took my phone and charger with me
and went to the airport
I wanted to arrive but didn’t want to see
my son sick in hospital
...I arrived to
On my way I booked a ticket
I headed to the airport
and when I arrived
The place was full of security officers
?Why me? Why did they choose me
?Why don’t you carry any luggage with you
?Why are you travelling in such a way
My son, was the answer
I was crying. I told them that my son
was in critical condition at the hospital
and inspection took more time
than expected
Rather than questioning me for 10 minutes
They spent a long time
until I boarded the plane
Five hours passed as if they were
thirty years. During this time
I thought everything was only a dream
It’s impossible
My life is different
What’s going on? Why is it
?changing? Is it reality
I only thought it was a
dream that would end soon
After 5 hours, the plane
finally landed in Dusseldorf’s airport
I arrived and found... I found
two Palestinian students waiting for me
So it wasn’t a dream
This means everything is real
the things
Everything was real
This dream won’t end
they took me to the hospital by car
We arrived to University Hospital of
Dusseldorf Center for Pediatrics
I went through a crowd of Palestinian
students who were standing at the door
Coming to console my wife
Consolation meant a critical condition
A healthy kid in a critical health
condition... suddenly
.I entered. They gave me a mask to wear
Same procedures we apply today
.I wore a uniform too and entered
,When I looked in front of me
I saw my happy little son whom I was
playing with two weeks ago
.I saw a piece of flesh
His body was black
I didn’t believe my eyes
.I was still hoping it was a dream
I wished it had been a dream
I wished to wake up from that nightmare
I couldn’t handle it. All the energy
in me. All the energy in my heart
...that I had collected and watched
piling them up like pebbles
burst out from my chest
I sat down watching him
.He was on his death bed
No signs of life were on his black body
I couldn’t withstand it so I left the room
to find my wife. I hugged her
She unconsciously told me that If we lost
him, she would bring me ten sons instead
She was lying
The German doctor approached ignoring
the mother and father’s feelings
?Where did they get him from
He might die. Nobody overcomes this
illness. The probability of staying alive
was very low. I wished the dream
would end. I wished everything
were a dream
O people. This is impossible
I was dreaming yesterday
We fight and fight to live
and now we’re knocking death’s door
.The doctor was void of feelings
He didn’t sympathize with us at all
I
.didn’t take his words into account
I believed in one only thing. This child
is the child of all Palestinians
who all
fight for life
I was sure he could do it. They said
he’d die and I was sure he’d survive
They were 36 hours. If everything went
fine, he may peacefully live
His body temperature was more than
forty-two degrees celsius
His heartbeats were highly pulsing
All his internal organs malfunctioned
Liver, kidneys, everything inside his
stomach stopped working
Nothing was working
The first 36 hours passed
and the doctor was sure he was in a
dangerous condition
We know how he will survive
We don’t know how he will live
Maybe blind
Maybe deaf
He may lose learning abilities
He may live with no limbs
He may live as a human
but like a body only
Nobody can bear this
It’s very hard. He might die
in front of you
.Twelve days passed
Medical delegations coming and going
.We were hoping to hear good news
We weren’t able to see what was going on
Did we want to see a corpse, or signs
of death on the skin, or dried fingers
or cirrhosis of body organs
Nothing was working but our faith
in Allah (God) was strong
We were sure our son would fight till the
last breath, even though he was a baby
because he wanted to survive, we were
patiently waiting at the door
After 12 days, a nurse came out
I still remember like it was yesterday
.She said our hero responded to treatment
We will transfer him to
the second hospital
To us, this was the critical part
They carried him in a helicopter
along with 5 doctors
I still remember it was yellow and small
...It flew up high and away
.We are in our city and we know no one
?How about moving to another city
Moving to a faraway city. We
don’t even know Iraq
I delegated my command to Allah
?Why this examination
?Why all of this patience
Thinking in the train. Moving
between cities
.Thinking about my son
?How will his life be
?How will he feel
?How will people accept him
We were a family whose son was
.between life and death
Ideas were flooding in. Finally, we
arrived to Mannheim city
.At the hospital, we met the doctors
Sign the documents
Here, stamp. We finished all procedures
We had to wait for 2-3 days
for the surgery
After 12 hours
they called us from the hospital
Hello, be at the hospital now
Another surgery is recommended. They
performed one 2-3 days ago
.We started to run crazily
We ran until we reached the hospital
In Germany, operation rooms
are underground. We met the doctor
He told us that they would perform another
surgery. Please stay outside
It required 5 hours
That surgery was necessary otherwise
he would die
After 2 hours, the doctor called us. He
asked us to meet him quickly
We left everything and ran to the hospital
We arrived to the clinic’s door
.The doctor showed up
He didn’t die, he shouted
You must take a decision. We
diagnosed his limbs. They’re lifeless
They’re just dead
So you either choose to amputate
his limbs
Or he’d die in 2 to 3 days
This decision was harder than death itself
This thing is harder than death
Death is easier
It’s easier
I remember myself running back and forth
the hospital until I gathered my strength
and went to the doctor
,I told him, I accept, a lump of flesh
blind, I agree, deaf, it’s fine
.Without limbs, I give up. I surrendered
I only wanted my son to survive
His shape never mattered anymore. His
abilities... It’s fine
We took the decision to amputate his limbs
The surgery was over after 2 hours. I
saw the child in front of me
with no limbs
They cut off two legs in the first surgery
It was weird to see your 10-month-old son
disabled
You’ll stop thinking about your days or
about your life, you’ll think of his life
He’ll live in a different way
Nobody could withstand the scene
The heart can’t bear such a feeling
Thirty six surgeries
Amputating the four limbs
Transplanting new skin just pulling it
from the head and after 2 weeks
transplanting another. They changed
everything. Our happiness was limitless
when he opened his eyes and saw his
bottle of milk. He followed it by the eyes
We felt overjoyed
.He could see
.He was looking around
We were thankful
This is very important to us
He could see
He had no limbs, but he could hear
No limbs. It’s okay
Thanks God he’s alive
He survived
They were 5 months of severe torture
My wife played an important role
My wife was a patient woman. Very patient
She gave me strength
.After 5 months, we decided to leave
Abboud’s limbs were cut off
and he received intensive care
We either had to live in Germany or leave
back to our country. We decided to leave
Better die in Al-Quds
The stones of Al-Quds will give us the
support we need to persist. We will be
between our beloved. They will provide us
with love and support
.Our country will support us
We will feel rooted
We decided to leave with a different child
who looks incomplete but
is complete with his mind, perseverance
and determination
Now, let me introduce Abboud to you
Even though he is disabled, he isn’t
...different. Here you go Abboud
Hello, I’m Abdelatif Ghaith, a determined
challenger, and up to the challenge
Abboud is fully integrated. He’s
different by shape, but similar by heart
He goes to an ordinary school and dreams
about a good life. This is our message to
all challengers
They are an integral part of our society
Everyone must treat them well
Thank you all
Yes, she’s here
Thank you for your feelings. The message
is from Allah. He chose us on purpose
We are a conservative family and I took
great care of my eldest son. When I was
studying in Germany, I devoted my life to
my son. I took great care of him
This is our fate
The message was from Allah. He wanted us
to carry such a responsibility
and be reliable
Thanks to Allah
we’re working on Abboudi’s abilities
to be a role model
for many people
Many people tell us that we’ve touched
their lives. They want to start
.We must be an idol for others
We must keep going
Abboud will grow up normally as any other
kid. You’ll see
in all societies, especially Al-Quds
which is our goal
Thank you so much
Let’s go